I'm back here with Pete Koomen again.
And Pete, I let you talk a little bit
about the user experience and what is
was so important for Optimizely to get
right about your user's experience
>> Sure.
So when we started Optimizely,
we set out to make an A/B testing
platform that anybody could use.
And, in fact, our slogan was A/B
testing you'll actually use.
And we weren't the first people
to build an A/B testing platform.
People have been A/B testing, frankly,
since the days of mail catalogs,
back in the early 1900s.
The approach that we took to it was that
products are out there that let you do
this, but they were really hard to use.
And for that reason most people just
weren't doing this kind of optimization,
and this insight came.
My co-founder spent nine months or
ten months working on
the Obama campaign in 2008.
And he was the Director
of Analytics there, and
he ran a bunch of A/B tests for
the campaign.
And those tests resulted in
a lot of additional money and
a lot of additional volunteers
being captured by the campaign.
And the insight coming out of it was,
hey,
this is really valuable, but boy that
was tough, that was a pain in the ass.
And so that was kind of
the insight that we started with.
And we just thought, there's
probably an easier way to do this.
And so our approach from the outset
was this is a problem that's,
oh sorry, this is something
that's already out there.
It's our job to make it much,
much easier, and so
we had to focus on the user.
And we built a way to create and
run an A/B test in a very visual way.
We tried to design it in
such a way that a marketer,
who didn't have an engineering
background, could do.
Yeah.
>> So you would definitely say it was
more of like a painkiller idea to
solve someone's pain point around
using A/B testing platforms
than anything else.
>> Absolutely.
So, and in fact what we discovered was
that the pain that was there was so
significant that most people
just weren't using this product.
And so at the outset, our biggest
competitor was not some other company
trying to sell a product, our biggest
competitor was non-consumption.
>> Yeah.
>> And
these companies just they'd heard about
A/B testing and some of them had tried
it, they just never were able
to get it to work for them.
And that's what we tried to solve.